أريد أن أنتقل الآن إلى أوكرانيا
وقوات باشمان فاغنر تعلن
النصر هناك، ما هو الوضع على
الأرض، لذا فإن أحد الأشياء الأساسية التي يجب
وضعها في الاعتبار أن باولا هي التي تقع
هنا نوعًا ما في منتصف
الجبهة الشرقية أه إذا  أه ما
قالته مجموعة فاغنر صحيح يعني أن
الروس قد حصلوا بشكل أساسي على
نقطة محورية يمكنهم التحرك منها
شمالًا أو جنوبًا في هذه
المنطقة بالذات، فإذا ذهبت إلى الجبهة الشرقية
بالتفصيل فما هو الشيء الرئيسي  أن
باكموت في طريقه إلى محرقة الجثث،
ما يريد الروس فعله هو أنهم
يريدون الاستيلاء على ما تبقى من
إقليم دونيتسك، منطقة دونيتسك
هنا، ما سيفعله ذلك بعد ذلك هو من
هنا إلى هنا، منح الروس المزيد من
السيطرة، ومنحهم المزيد من الأراضي، ومنحهم المزيد من الأراضي.
لهم المزيد من النفوذ في تلك
المرحلة بالذات الآن بالنسبة لباكمود على وجه التحديد، ما
ترونه هنا هو المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا،
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها أوكرانيا، ما
يقوله الروس ومجموعة فاغنر على وجه التحديد هو أنهم
سيطروا بشكل أساسي على هذه المنطقة
هنا، الأوكرانيون
يحسبون ذلك في  الحقيقة أن الأوكرانيين
يقولون إنهم تمكنوا من القيام بأشياء
هنا في هذه المناطق التي حررت
تلك الأجزاء من منطقة باكمود من
القوات الروسية، لذلك لا تزال هذه المنطقة محل
نزاع إلى حد ما لأنك
تعرف ما يقوله باغوسيان أه كما تعلم
في هذا النوع من مقاطع الفيديو،
هناك شيء واحد ولكن بقية المدينة
تبدو بشكل أساسي مثل هذا وهو موضع
خلاف كبير لأن لديك هذه
الارتفاعات الشاهقة هنا والتي يتم استخدامها
كنقاط دخول للقناصين الذين يتم
استخدامهم فيها  العديد من الطرق المختلفة التي
تعرفها تعني حقًا القتال الحضري
على نطاق واسع هنا